nor lives in a residential facility for
young people in paderborn in north
central germany his family are still in
the Syrian city of Homs he stays in
contact with them by phone nor misses
his mother most of all his father
disappeared two years ago Noor's mother
sent him to Germany instead of his 16
year old brother because it was less
expensive traffickers charged three
thousand euros for nor they would have
charged six thousand for his brother how
are you fine and you well I'm fine too
if we get there will we live in a
refugee shelter or in a proper home I
will shoot the first in a shelter then
we'll look for an apartment or something
Nadia took love for you and it lolly we
really hope that we can join you no one
in NORs family thought that the process
would take so long how can a child live
for so long without his mother but the
wheels of German bureaucracy turned
slowly nor has only just been officially
listed as a refugee after 18 months of
waiting hulett ela works at the facility
and is helping nor with all the
paperwork he has to wade through Ravana
know we talked to the attorney mrs. lamb
/ and she said that now you're
officially listed as a refugee you can
apply for permission to have your family
join you come down and back offer
millions was I'm feeling Starion yeah
right she said that only my mom could
come and then my mom has to what happens
next what do you mean that's after my
mom comes to German agent good
listen via via dog off button does okay
first we have to wait until she's
officially listed as a refugee read on I
[ __ ] off then she can apply to have her
other three children join her who does
but she'll have to leave them behind for
the time being and find someone to look
after them in Syria and even being
filmed a European offers a locked d for
lampa have two alphas are mrs. lampo
also said that your mother will have to
grant her power of attorney said that
she can make the application on your
mother's behalf even Armin van Armitage
tailender yeah yeah I noticed a business
list when did you last talk to your mum
mama yeah yesterday what did you talk
about did she have anything that she'd
like you to take care of oh did oh come
on boys yah yah yes she said I've got to
help my family come to Germany yeah and
bring him loose yeah but we told her
when we and a translator talked to her a
while back that there's nothing you can
do in this process I first all fast yeah
I can't do anything either you think of
it as well she thinks that I can she
thinks it'll be quicker cuz I'm a kid
early the next morning nor heads off to
school which is located in the suburbs
it's a comprehensive school the refugee
children are taught on two different
levels in small separate groups and also
in regular classes with the rest of the
students at homes classes were
interrupted frequently by the civil war
nor fell behind in some subjects but
he's catching up fast now I had to hear
would uh it took I think he's doing fine
he gets along well with the other
students don't come speaks German
especially well for the amount of time
he's been here so that's a credit to him
I love him cool Attila plans to send the
power of attorney document to the lawyer
who's handling the case it could take
months for the German immigration
authorities to process it he's a bar the
clerk at the immigration office and the
attorney both said that it would go more
quickly if Noah's mother and the rest of
the family just packed up and left for
Europe without official permission out
of Attila khanoomi gonk but that trip
would be expensive and probably
dangerous too
nor and his advisor have done all they
can they'll just have to wait and see
what happens next